hey guys Pete here I've been working on
ideas from my twin peak season one
rewatched series this was the
overwhelming favorite idea from my
patrons on patreon so I've been thinking
about it for over a week now one key
question that comes to mind is rooted in
the end of season 3 so if you haven't
completed watching that yet this will
contain major spoiler you're gonna want
to watch something else instead with
that out of the way the question I'm
referring to is if flora wasn't killed
then do the events of season 1 and
season 2 of Twin Peaks still exist this
is a complicated question and one we
certainly can't answer conclusively I'm
gonna be speculating and I could be
wrong the only thing I'm sure of is that
some of you will agree with my thinking
and some of you won't it's just the
nature of how the story has been told
and I'm okay with that
my initial reaction when watching the
finale of Twin Peaks the return was that
after we saw Pete go fishing and Laura's
body disappear from the shore this would
have meant that Laura was never murdered
and therefore Agent Dale Cooper would
never have needed to travel to Twin
Peaks to investigate in the first place
I mentioned as much in my first finale
recap but I've been thinking about it
ever since the evidence is clear here we
saw Cooper intervene and we saw her body
wrapped in plastic disappear Pete never
discovers the body so he never calls the
Twin Peaks sheriff harry s truman what
happens after he intervenes is what I
think is the best evidence for the fate
of the events of the original series and
I also think there are some pertinent
clues in the secret history of Twin
Peaks I'm assuming if you're still
watching this video you've watched the
return to conclusion but that only some
of you guys have actually read the
secret history the reason I went back to
the book when thinking about this video
was based on the idea that there were
several discrepancies that fans quickly
picked up on in the book after it was
released like instantly afterwards there
were certain things that didn't add up
and didn't match with what we saw in the
first
seasons for the most part these were
character details and some larger
omissions like removing any Blackburn
from Norma's family these have been a
mystery and we're all waiting to learn
more when the final dossier comes out
next month because mark frost has said
that things will eventually make sense
after seeing agent Cooper go back in
time with the help of Philip Jeffries I
immediately wondered if this could be
the reason the secret histories
discrepancies existed of course it's not
that simple because the murder of Laura
Palmer is mentioned in the book agent
Cooper's return from the Red Room and
his meeting with major Briggs occurs
just as we saw it at the end of season
two and heard it referred to in season
three so the universe that the book
exists in has the murder of Laura Palmer
in ball of course there could be a
chance that when the final dossier comes
out all the references to that will be
gone but I really think that's unlikely
what I also think is unlikely is that
David Lynch and Mark Frost as a team
writing the story and then David Lynch
directing the story on his own after
they came up with the whole idea of the
return I just think it's super unlikely
that they would have made this alternate
version of history that doesn't include
their first big collaboration which was
a very popular and successful thing when
it happened and that is Twin Peaks
season 1 in season 2 and I am getting
ready to do my rewatch as I mentioned so
does that stuff still exist there have
been plenty of different really good
kind of theories that are out there
after the return finished up about what
actually happened at the end one part
that isn't necessarily fleshed out in
any of those because it's not the most
major thing that happens is that idea of
what happened to Twin Peaks the original
one the story that we liked the one that
all those characters used to inhabit
if the timeline changed and Laura was
never murdered that doesn't mean that
she never exists
did or for instance that harry s truman
was never the share of him Twin Peaks or
that any of those characters ever
existed I mean that stuff's pretty
obvious I think to everyone that Twin
Peaks still exists there's just an
alternate version of the reality there
where we don't have all those characters
coming together especially agent tell
Cooper in the investigation of Laura's
murder
so is that reality like is what happened
after he went back in time that that
murder never happened or is it something
else I tend to think that it's something
else so I don't have a smoking gun but
like I said I just don't think Frost and
Lynch would erase that whole memory of
this thing that we were all a part of
and there's other stuff as well most
fans spent the majority of season three
waiting for agent Cooper to return and
he was in the Red Room for 25 years in
that reality so what was he doing he was
doing stuff right he wasn't just sitting
there I mean he could have just been
sitting there but we kind of have some
hints later on that he was interacting
with Diane and maybe some other things
so to think that he was just basically
in limbo for 25 years seems pretty
unlikely we also know that major Briggs
had been hibernating as he told Bill
Hastings and we can see that he had some
influence over events as well what's the
best reason that I think that this
wouldn't have happened that way that
twin peak season one in season 2 still
do exist and in fact that is the actual
real timeline and the one that he went
back to alter is actually an alternate
timeline
are you following well I think it is
because while he was in the Red Room
being agent Cooper for 25 years when he
came out he understood what the plan was
he still had the same plan that we heard
Gordon Cole refer to when he explained
it to Albert and Tammy he didn't explain
it to us or he didn't explain the
details but he did explain that there
was a plan it involved Briggs and
involved agent Cooper and it was all
ready in motion before the 25-year gap
so when Cooper came back he was
following a plan he was doing things
that he had started and had continued to
work on while he was gone in my opinion
so if we're thinking about this
character that everyone loves I feel
like he wouldn't have gone back and
changed history if that would have meant
that everything would have disappeared
from before when time travel exists in a
story it creates it's difficult because
it creates a lot of paradoxes which we
all learned about when we watch back to
the future however many years ago
what really shouldn't have happened
though was that Cooper shouldn't have
made a decision that would drastically
change everything
what he should have done is he should
have made a decision that went along
with his plan that Gordon Cole knew
about that we realized that Phillip
Jeffries knew about since he aided him
and that had a real purpose which was to
defeat Judy
it wasn't about saving Laura because
Laura needed saved agent Cooper
understood that Laura was a tool created
by the firemen so that's kind of really
important when we look at this Cooper
wouldn't do it
the other things that we have to think
about as well are the way that Briggs
explained what he was doing to Bill
Hastings and Ruth Davenport we know that
in season two major Briggs was abducted
he went to what we assumed was the White
Lodge based on his own description in
the secret history we learn a lot more
about that and so I went back and I went
through what he described and he had he
does a very thorough description of the
way that time was and we saw this in the
third season when he came and gave the
canister to his wife to hold on to for
the future events we saw this where he
had shown Bobby as a child where
Jackrabbits palace was how to open the
canister so on and so forth in ducky
Milford's farewell letter to major
Briggs whenever he
was getting ready to leave the project
at I mean he didn't know he was gonna
die he knew that Briggs had disappeared
he was gonna marry Lana and he was going
to step back at that point from
listening post alpha mark frost put a
lot of time into this because this is
the final chapters of the secret history
so he went to great detail to explain
what milford thought at the end of all
of his years of chasing after this
unknown phenomena what he wanted Briggs
to do and it wouldn't make sense to do
all of that just to put out another book
nine months or a year later that erases
it all from history so I you know
circumstantial evidence sure but I think
it's still rather important now the
firemen's plan is probably the one thing
that is kind of gone into pretty deeply
in the better theories that are out
there about season three we also have
the log lady and everything that she
said to hawk in season three and her
insistence that Laura was the one well
it could be pretty straightforward in
that Laura was the one who was meant to
stop all the evil that's been lurking
around the woods in Twin Peaks since
anyone can remember we know pretty
conclusively now that that all came from
Judy we had episode eight that kind of
showed that we had what happened at the
end and yeah I mean Gordon Cole gave us
the answer
Judy was an extreme negative force that
had to be stopped and they had a plan to
do that
the fireman theory that I really think
is closest to correct as far as what
Frost and Lynch were thinking about when
they wrote the story is the one where
they go when they cross over they go
into a pocket dimension or alternate
reality and that's when they face Judy
at the very end of episode 18 now you
don't have to agree with that theory to
agree with the idea that whatever Cooper
was doing there and what
ever he was he was doing that to follow
the fireman's plan so if we look at the
time when he went back to save Laura or
at least what looked like saving Laura
what he could have actually been doing
is just pausing that timeline to skew we
saw Sarah Palmer who we all pretty much
agree was being inhabited by Judy at the
end stabbing at the photo of Laura and
well as the screen was sort of glitching
out and things were changing and that
kind of does look a lot like she would
be following after Laura into this other
dimension if the firemen had set it up
so based on those things based on what
have sort of always seemed like the most
important characters to the mythology
side of things to me which are obviously
the giant firemen the log lady major
Briggs and Phillip Jeffries they all
seem to be working towards that same
goal and I don't know why we need to
erase season one in season two from the
timeline in order to say that their plan
would have been different somehow you
know what I mean like I just think it it
all sort of points to that stuff is
still real but whenever Cooper went with
Phillip Jeffries and used the infinity
clock or whatever you want to call it
and goes back and pools Laura it was all
part of the plan to get Judy to chase
her somewhere where they could finally
face her head on the idea between Briggs
and Jeffries time-travel shows that once
you go across things do not necessarily
go in a straight line certainly not a
linear timeline so all of that stuff
could have been arranged at any time
over the last 25 years and if you
remember from fire walk with me Jeffries
basically goes on a two-year skip when
he goes from Buenos Aires to
Philadelphia so we know that when
they're jumping around we don't know a
whole lot about the coordinates other
than their portals but we noticed that
whenever they passed through time
doesn't behave normally
like I said mark frost went into great
detail about what major brakes thought
happened to him in his trip to the White
Room or the White Lodge so him going
back in time and plucking lore doesn't
really screw things up that much if it's
done in that way the other thing we have
to keep in mind is the development of
the story and the mythology when they
were writing season 1 they may have had
no real idea about any of this stuff a
lot of it kind of seems like they made
it up as they went along as far as the
lodges and different things are
concerned so I think if they're
interjecting this idea whenever they're
coming up with the idea of season 3 and
what it's about and how it ends I really
don't see it coming up that hey let's
destroy the first two seasons just to
piss off all the fans you know what I
mean like I think instead that they just
elaborated on this plan this plan
happened it needed to accomplish this
saying of taking care of duty and all
this stuff sort of built out from that
but like I said right at the beginning I
could be wrong because it's all
speculation and I'm really interested to
see what you guys have to think so this
is the primer episode one is the next
Twin Peaks video I'm gonna do that's
gonna be my rewatch so definitely give
this video a like definitely come over
and think about joining in on the
patreon I don't think these videos are
gonna get a lot of views the Twin Peaks
hype has died down so it's mostly gonna
be the more diehards are gonna watch and
I love the idea of doing the rewatch all
the way through but at this point I have
to be honest that I think that those
people who have already came over to the
patreon are basically making this happen
you know and I really want to thank
everybody who's come over there to help
out because I'm a paycheck to paycheck
youtuber you know what I mean like I
have to make enough to cover my expenses
or else I have to go do something else
besides make youtube videos so please
think about that please like the video
if you enjoyed it please follow me on
Twitter subscribe to my channel
definitely give me your ideas in the
comments and thanks for watching guys
I'll talk to you soon